we won't call it quits we call it the
start
please don't talk to me
no more about it so obviously you know I
wanted to get Colin and Brendan back
together since In Bruges days and I was
sort of in a breakupy kind of situation
back then and just trying to explore the
sadness of that you know as as deeply
sad as those things can be you used to
be nice that you never used to be
[Music]
Another Universe I'm here because we
need your help very busy today whole
time to help you you were grappling with
the question of how do we exist in the
chaos and the noise of Modern Life you
know like how do you make sense of any
of it we live in a world where we're
constantly distracted by so many things
and one of the only things we have to
give each other is our attention
thank you
you'll make your movies
you will do your art and you'll remember
how it hurts so you know what I'm saying
all of my films I consider to be
personal films but I've never really
made a movie that is about I've lived
experience as opposed to just a metaphor
to something else I had never written
anything with anybody and I didn't know
how whether it would work I mean it just
sort of flowed out it was really it was
it was a fascinating thing I had a blast
foreign
you want to dance the mask you must
service the composer you got to
sublimate yourself your ego and yes your
identity the old saying inspiration is
you know 90 sweat incredible things can
happen when people come together and
they're all aligned for the same aim you
have a chance then there's a lot of
people that work very very hard you know
inspiration is important obviously but
there's a certain point where you just
have to be very lucky
[Music]
If Today Was Your Last Day of life um
I have no idea I almost look at
filmmaking as like putting up
sociological experiments and trying to
make an interesting example when we fail
why do we fail never argue with an idiot
they'll only bring you down to their
level and beat you with experience
[Music]